- from New York is Norina hurts she is
the author of the debt threat thank you
for joining us thank you Steve having me
on why do you consider third-world debt
a problem well the world's poorest
countries sub-saharan Africa a region
where 26 million people are hiv/aids
infected is having to pay out 30 million
dollars every single day on debt service
just think how many doctors and teachers
and medicines and schoolbooks that money
could otherwise be used for what is your
message to the US and the other Western
countries the message is very clear we
have to cancel the debts of the world's
poorest countries when that means that a
country cannot provide basic health care
shelter sanitation education to its
people because it has to repay its debts
we have to have action on this now there
is a real state of emergency in the
developing world and it's an emergency
that we can do something about there is
a proposal that's been put forth by the
US government it was presented to
British Prime Minister Tony Blair last
week at the g7 finance ministers meeting
can you outline the details of what the
Bush administration is and isn't
suggesting to France and Germany and
Great Britain what's happened is the
world's developed country leaders have
acknowledged at long last the existing
ways of debt relief just ain't working
and there are various competing
proposals now on the table for what to
do next United and really the issue kind
of revolves around as always who's going
to foot the bill for debt cancellation
the United Kingdom has a proposal
whereby the IMF the International
Monetary Fund will sell off some of its
gold reserves to finance part of this
debt cancellation the United States has
another proposal which doesn't agree
that the gold should be sold off and
then
sted says that the World Bank should
play a bigger part in financing the debt
cancellation itself but at the moment no
one can agree on who will actually foot
the bill and whilst they can't agree
millions of people are actually dying as
a consequence what are the points from
your book Norina Hertz is that for the
price of four stealth bombers a hundred
and fifty five million children can be
sent to school for a year do you view
this as an either/or when it comes to
military spending by the US and other
Western nations well I mean governments
have limited resources and they have to
decide how to allocate them in terms of
national security we're really operating
in this kind of old Cold War paradigm
where we think of military expenditure
is the best way to protect ourselves but
of course in today's climate that isn't
so and when you have a developing world
that is incredibly poor what we're
seeing is that that's extremist
organizations are gaining public support
in these regions because when the state
doesn't have money to repay to provide
health or hospitals or schools extremist
organizations come in and they do so in
their stead and they're getting a lot of
grassroots support as a result so in
Afghanistan you have terrorist training
groups you know training terrorists
extremist groups but but also digging
wells and providing bakeries so when we
think about how best to protect
ourselves we have to look at development
aid as a part of that package and that's
why it is worth while comparing military
expenditure to development aid and
seeing that really we've got the package
very wrong we're talking about the third
world debt with marina Hertz who's the
author of a book on the subject she is
currently a visiting fellow at the
University of Cambridge she attended
college there where she earned her
doctorate she's also a graduate of
University College in London and earned
her MBA from Wharton she's written a
number of books and is joining us from
our studios at Pace University in
midtown Manhattan our phone lines are
open you can also email us journal at
c-span org Bethlehem Pennsylvania good
morning
thank you for taking my call I am I'm
very curious as to who do you think's
going to handle our debts we're about
seven trillion dollars in debt and we
have an eleven trillion dollar trade
imbalance and I got a good feeling that
President Bush wants to take that Social
Security money and give it to the
financial institutions they're about
ready to crash I've been reading this in
European news I've been watching German
and British television and I think we're
really in a lot worse shape than most
Americans know now you certainly
sympathize with your position on helping
these other countries but I think the
whole role financial situation is about
ready to collapse thank you I mean
obviously you have a terrible looming
debt crisis of your own you're
absolutely right and even if you look at
consumer debt figures in this country
they're escalating at an alarming rate
but you know when people are borrowing
money and getting into debt at least
they have VCRs to Shaffir it DVD players
houses cars in the world's poorest
countries the people there they've got
nothing to show for the debt because
actually what happened was during the
Cold War at the time when these
countries really got into the debts that
they're in today we in the West were
bankrolling the most tyrannical and
corrupt dictators the world has ever
seen they stole the money the people in
the countries never benefited from it
and yet they today are being asked to
foot the bill thirty-year right that
Saddam Hussein was provided with loans
amounting to around a hundred billion
dollars several times
Iraq's GDP during the 1980s by
governments intent on serving their own
geopolitical purposes half of this money
came from Arab states led by Saudi
Arabia in order to support Iraq's
invasion of Iran on top of this came
seven billion dollars worth of credits
from the Russians six billion from the
French several billion dollars from the
Germans and British and at least ten
billion dollars from the United States
can you explain well I mean you know in
order to further geopolitical interests
in order to have Iraq on the right side
during that period but also more
importantly in the Iraq case
in order to further corporate interests
the West and other countries bankrolls
Saddam Husein so that for example there
was a case of chemical weapons plant for
Luger number two just outside of Baghdad
built with hundreds of millions of
dollars worth of United Kingdom loans in
this case lent the money is lent even
though in the British Parliament
questions were raised saying why are we
learning money which we know will be
used for a chemical weapons plant why
are we lending money that can be used so
that Saddam can produce nerve agents
this is after the world already knew
that had been gassing tens of thousands
of Kurds but the British trade minister
at the time said well we have to do this
in order to support our trade interests
with Iraq so really skewed lending and
then the Iraqi people were being asked
to pay this bill to pay for the knives
that Saddam II is to slaughter them
Manchester New Hampshire for noreña
hurts good morning good morning I just
like to challenge your yes statement
that not forgiving the debt is killing
people
basically nothing is has changed the
fact that they owe money has no effect
on their daily lives with the exception
is what you are saying is that if we
forgive the death they can borrow more
money which they're not going to pay
back later on so that's what you're
really saying you want it forgiven so
that they'll be able to borrow borrow
money in the future and once again let's
use it so you know to say that it's
killing people it is really fallacious I
really object to how you've laid this
out because Nazaire the country with the
highest infant mortality in the world is
currently paying out more on debt
service than it is on health care
Cameroon Sierra Leone Mauritania all
paying out more on debt service than
they are on education the world's
poorest countries sub-saharan Africa
paying
out in debt service 85% of all the aid
flows that coming in you've got to
remember this is a region where 40
million children will lose a parent to
hiv/aids within ten years sister say
that repaying the debt has no
consequence is obviously absurd but you
do raise a point that is worth spending
a little bit more time on and this is
the point
well these countries just going to kind
of get into debt again we need at the
same time as counseling debt to reach
deep in our pockets and give more in the
form of grants to it's very clear I mean
the world's richest countries all signed
out to this thing the Millennium
Development Goals which said that by
2015 the goal was to have the world's
poorest countries see infant mortality
have poverty halved huge progress and
kind of see a number of kids who go to
school we're not gonna reach these goals
and we all know we're not gonna reach
these goals unless the rich world gives
more in the form of aid 2.7 percent of
GDP is what each country is supposed to
be giving in order to reach this 2015
goal Britain isn't anywhere near that at
least not anywhere near that the United
States is only spending 0.14 percent of
its GDP on aid at the moment unless the
rich world gets with it it's not only
the poor world that's gonna be destroyed
it's retton's us all Colorado Springs
Colorado is our next caller good morning
good morning I'd like to I really agree
that we need to apply age where we're
it's it's starting and but the problem I
have is the last time we really helped
Africa we we gave lots of medications
and they ended up in Europe and the
governments of Africa were making profit
off the medications that were supposed
to go to the people we need to make sure
that there's some kind of accountability
and to make sure the people are getting
the medications that they are supposed
to be getting yeah you are absolutely
right and that's why in my new book the
death threats i I really address this
question because we have got to accept
that in some developing countries the
interests of the poor the needy the sick
and the marginalized are not per why
their leaders and in order to deal with
this problem in order that debt relief
and even aid does reach those who most
need it we have to create a mechanism
whereby monies are protected and
actually put aside for the purposes of
poverty alleviation health care
education and development and we can use
mechanisms similar to trust fund
mechanisms in order to do that and there
is precedent for this in the developing
world in the area of conservation where
monies have been put aside for
environmental purposes in trust funds
and actually reach there and Uganda has
although not as formalized a trust fund
as I proposed put 97 percent of debt
relief savings into a fund and as a
result we see primary school enrolment
having doubled there over the past three
years and we also see real progress made
by that government on their hiv/aids
crisis but you're absolutely right we
have to protect monies so that they
reach those that need them and do not
get wasted or stolen our conversation is
with Norina Hertz she is joining us from
midtown Manhattan she's the author of a
book that was first published last fall
in Great Britain here in this country
the title is the debt threat how debt is
destroying the developing world and
threatening us all published by
HarperCollins Philadelphia is next good
morning good morning how are you first
of all I want to know whatever happened
to the old king charity begins at home
and number one that woman stood near
Chris he's trying to sell a book and I
and I'm very much against all these
foreigners coming over here and telling
us what to do and how to do it so I wish
you've returned to anyone we belong
thank you color hurry up thank you for
your hospitality
this is a fantastic country I mean it's
the country that has values and
principles which you know can provide an
amazing steer to the rest of this world
and this country is actually incredibly
generous when it comes to private
charitable giving private individuals
and private corporations give a lot of
charity here but in terms of foreign aid
and the percentage of gross domestic
product that is given to foreign aid the
United States really isn't pulling its
weight in the way that it could which is
you know which really is sad because
this country can give so much and play
such a fantastic role out there in the
world and yet this administration is not
putting his money into these purposes I
mean I don't want to romanticize Britain
and I don't want to romance those Europe
and when we're doing terrible things
when it comes to development ourselves
the European Union is continuing to
subsidize each and every cow to the tune
of $2 50 a day when over a billion
people live on less than that so it's a
matter of all of us collectively
doing something to create a better world
not only for our own sakes but for
future generations to Norina hearths
every January in February this network
devotes a number of hours to the World
Economic Forum that takes place in Davos
Switzerland what is the background to
that meeting how often have people like
yourselves and others met there and what
comes from those sessions well yeah I've
just come back from there myself a
couple of weeks ago and what it is it's
a gathering of the world's business
leaders and political leaders and
increasingly activists and people from
pressure groups and non-governmental
organizations getting together to really
look at what are the key issues in the
world today and what are we going to do
collective
to address them and I spoke on a few
panels at the Forum this year and what
was incredible this year and I've been
going for four years now what was really
different this year was that for the
first time there were sessions on for
example Africa or development that were
absolutely packed oversubscribed people
kind of queueing to get in to a session
on Africa but they were it was amazing I
mean a panel with Tony Blair was Bill
Clinton with Bill Gates Bono the rock
star Beck a the president of South
Africa a bus surge of the president of
Nigeria macapa the president of Tanzania
managing to get thousands literally over
2,000 of the world's top business
leaders and politicians in a room to
discuss Africa now that isn't just
because there's a moral imperative
dealing with that region it's not just
because it's a travesty that 34,000
children are dying every day there
because of poverty related diseases but
it's also because people in the rich
world are increasingly realizing that to
allow the exclusion and marginalization
of that area is to our own peril
Los Angeles is our next caller good
morning thanks for joining us yes thank
you very much
marina I'd like to talk to you about the
potential of this country becoming a
third world I'm a longshoreman every
contract up and down the west coast is
owned by a communist country or or an
oriental country they control and own
the ships the cranes the chassis the
containers the cargo and if they break
the Longshoremen's Union they'll have
nothing but Korean labor in here we have
a border that's wide open they have
shown the Republicans are trying to
impress the public in regard to their
security and what they do is check us as
longshoremen and not the people that are
coming in from across the borders and or
our foreigners they have spent 54
billion million dollars on Homeland
Security they claim they bought a couple
of x-ray machines
the numbers that they continue to x-ray
during the day is falling off because
they're getting lakhs this I don't know
where all the money's going I don't know
what the republic's are doing with it we
work for a company called SSA the
president of that company as a
heavyweight politician he has locked up
the stevedoring operation in Iraq
without contract bidding we're looking
at and the problem with the borders if
they want to control those borders why
don't they put a hiring hall on the
Mexican side and charge them to come
here to go to work
thank you why didn't they why didn't why
don't we work on making life so good for
people in developing countries so that
they don't even want to come here I mean
why don't we reframe it so that we look
at why don't we make sure that people
have opportunities where they live so
that they don't need to come elsewhere
why don't we mean like life acceptable
for people elsewhere so that their kids
will be able to go to school so that
their kids will get health care if
they're sick so that they don't need to
travel and cross borders and come
elsewhere and leave their families
that's how we should be thinking about
these issues noreña hurts who's also the
author of the silent takeover as we get
this next call from Fort Myers Florida
good morning good morning how are you hi
my question is or my proposal is I I
agree with you we should help fair world
countries but I don't believe there's
any correlation with money and
extremists there's always going to be
extremists and if we help people out we
have to hunt down the extremists first
or they're gonna take over what's given
to them and it is obviously a nuanced
argument the one between poverty and
terrorism because we all know that many
of the terrorists that we've heard of a
not poor the middle class or even rich
and we also know of course it would be
wrong to say that everyone poor goes and
becomes a terrorist or an extremist
because of course they don't but what we
do see is that when a country is
desperately poor and when a stay
it isn't providing schools or hospitals
to its people extremist organizations
are coming in and they're getting a lot
of support in Pakistan for example
they're announced 6,000 extremist
religious schools there where kids
aren't taught how to read and write I
mean they're taught how to fire a gun
and hate the West but the schools are
there and people are sending their kids
to their schools because the state isn't
providing sufficient normal secular
education for its some for it for its
population so there's a real danger that
when the state cannot provide monies or
isn't providing funds to its people or
services extremist organizations are and
that's part of the reason why it's in
all of our interest to ensure that
states are not using their pitiful
resources on first servicing debts to
the world's richest countries from the
book the debt threat our guest says our
political leaders will first have to be
convinced that this is what their
constituents 1 opinion has to be
massively mobilized but indifference in
apathy to the developing world's plight
are no longer viable viable options you
conclude by saying discuss it refine it
improve upon it but don't ignore it you
can't afford to next call is Brooklyn
New York good morning hurts I agree with
everything you said so far you're
wonderful but I was wondering the way
you have to try to convince some of the
people that are not on board yet is you
know you say you take the first say the
top of the bottom 10 countries in the
world that are really desperate you
relieve the debt and then you have to
figure out what to do to make these
economies viable if you can give us some
examples or solutions to these problems
and people you know the rich countries
they're actually paying for this we'll
say ok then you know that makes sense
because it's a practical solution and
we're not just throwing money you know
constantly at a problem that's never
going to be solved for example there's a
Oxfam for instance they had a campaign
with cotton farmers and I believe it's
Molly I'm not sure exactly which country
and I for there was but they're saying
that
America subsidizes their cotton farmers
is such a high rate that you know people
in these poor countries can't make a
living and you know the way to you know
you know solve this would be maybe fair
trade would be one one example of you
know solve the problem do you have in
other suggestions or a solutions to this
thank you thank you well I think really
if we think about Holy Trinity for
dealing with problems of development it
it's really debt relief aid and trade
because you're absolutely right the
world's poorest countries what can they
sell to us they can sell agricultural
products food products and also textiles
yet these textiles and agricultural
products are industries which we in the
developed world are subsidizing so we're
making it impossible for the world's
poorest countries to sell their products
to us they just can't they can't meet
our subsidies they just can't do it and
in fact they're losing two billion
dollars every single day it's estimated
in lost sales so if we're really serious
about giving the third world a chance to
earn its way out of misery then we have
to do something on the trade subsidy
front but even if countries don't have
subsidies on trade even if we deal with
that if a country is still having to pay
out in debt relief eighty-five percent
of its budget there won't be money for
roads there won't be money for education
there won't be money for health care so
countries again will not be able to
trade their way out of the problem so we
really have to look at it in these three
ways debt relief aid and trade and we
can get fantastic results I mean we see
in countries where debt relief has been
given or in countries where Aid has
increased as long as the monies are
actually used for sensible purposes and
that has to be a condition of all this
that we do protect the monies so that
they are used in sensible ways we see
already results like the Ugandan case
we're primary school enrollment has
trebled has doubled over the past few
years where they've made real progress
on their hiv-aids dealing with so we see
that it can work it's a matter of
creating the political will so that we
actually take action on this front but
isn't it really a double expenditure if
you want to call it that for the US and
other Western countries you wipe away
the aid and then you also provide an
infusion of cash millions or maybe
billions of dollars for roads and
bridges and infrastructure
this isn't gonna come for free this
isn't you know there is going to be a
cost attached to ensuring that the
developing world does develop but you
know a hundred and seventy billion
dollars is what it would cost for
example to cancel all the debts of
sub-saharan Africa that's less than the
u.s. cost of military operations in Iraq
so far so it's not a matter of available
resources it's a matter of what we
choose to do with them but that
investment that investment in the
developing world today is an investment
in the children in those countries in
the grandchildren of the children in
those countries it's an investment in
our environment because of course when
the country's poor the first thing it
does is it cuts down its rain forests it
allows dirty industries to pollute the
environment it doesn't prioritize the
environment it's we're buying a safer
world for all of us so although it will
cost today in terms of the future gains
wow they're priceless next call Honolulu
Hawaii good morning thank you for
joining us good morning yes I'm calling
from like I said you said from one of a
loop and basically once say I'm
originally from Peru in South America
and I just have a couple questions here
for for you guys and I was wondering how
forgiving the corrupt governments dead
in terrible countries will
will benefit their their people you know
like I said I'm from Peru and you know
year after year I've seen the country
just go down and is basically due to bad
management and also I wonder how you
know forgiving debt to African countries
where you know they have these AIDS
epidemic going on will will help the
people there when you know one of the
major problems there is it's a cultural
issue Thank You caller um well I think
we've just got to be very clear on this
that most of the monies borrowed by
developing countries were not actually
borrowed by their current governments
but by former governments many of whom
were terribly corrupt and we in the West
lent to them we lent to Suharto in
Indonesia we lent to Marcos in the
Philippines we lent her bachi in Nigeria
we lent him abouttwo in SE air I mean we
let we lent to Saddam Hussein I mean we
lent to some of the worst regimes in the
world in fact congressional hearings
currently taking place in the United
States have revealed that up to a third
of monies lent by the World Bank over
the past six decades was stolen not that
surprising when you think those were the
regime's they were lending to so I'm
saying we've got to cancel debts that
were lent to formerly dictatorial
corrupt regimes the people in those
countries they never elected those
dictators they didn't benefit from the
monies and they shouldn't have to pay
the price today they've already paid in
many other ways for having these
terrible regimes but you are right and I
stress that there should be one
condition for debt relief and that is
that the monies are protected so that
they do reach those that need them
because you're right we know that isn't
always so but there are mechanisms that
enable us to do it trust fund mechanisms
which enable us to protect monies so
that they actually reach those that need
them that's how we have to be thinking
about development today
we have to think it's a matter of
justice that the monies be cancelled but
also matter of justice that the monies
do reach those that need them and put in
place the mechanisms to ensure that
that's the case and in Europe based on
my proposals and my ideas
we now have worked within various
governments looking at how to make these
trust funds operational the book is
called the debt threat how the debt is
destroying the developing world and
threatening us all the author is Norina
Hertz who's a fellow at the University
of Cambridge in London and joins us from
midtown Manhattan as she continues her
book tour around the country thank you
for being with us thank you for having
me on President Bush is at the Justice
Department for the swearing in of the
80th attorney general Alberto Gonzales
he was formally voted in by the Senate a
week and a half ago and has been on the
job but this is a ceremonial ceremony
that the president is attending he's
attending the ceremonies for all of his
new cabinet appointees later in the day
the president will be meeting with the
head of the International Red Cross to
talk about the issue of the detainees in
Guantanamo and elsewhere the house is in
a pro forma session the Senate will
begin debate today on the nomination of
Michael Chertoff a vote is expected
tomorrow to be the next Secretary of
Homeland Security right now in the dirt